mandatory evacuations are in place for
eight counties along Florida's east
coast in a hurricane warning extends
north of Cape Canaveral almost to
Jacksonville that includes st. Augustine
Florida where mark Strassmann is Mark
how are the conditions there good
morning this is the bay front in st.
Augustine the most flood-prone area of
America's oldest city with a significant
band of rain around 1:30 this morning
and believe me there is more where that
came from we had wind gusts of 41 miles
an hour reported at the local airport
streets here are quiet there's a
mandatory evacuation order and a curfew
just ended when durian hits there could
be storm surge of up to 7 inches and as
always Beach communities are most at
risk one of them is summer island with
its oceanfront views and pricey homes
two hurricanes matthew and armored
battered it hard in the last three years
homes are destroyed and replaced there's
new hurricane protection there massive
rocks and berms made of stone and sand
to hold off future storms they've
already been breached by Dorian's
leading edge and that has exposed the
homes to more misery as you can see
they've done a lot of protective
measures and barriers here trying to
save these people's you know valuables
in their homes and their livelihoods
however you know with the rocks here to
our right to our east and the new berm
with all the new Sawgrass and grass
behind us nothing's gonna stop Mother
Nature which is going to keep on coming
which we have another 24 hours and 40
minutes here yeah this place could be in
trouble
this could be seriously in trouble and I
believe based on the current breakdown
there there could be multiple breaks in
the inlet right now is low tide out of
the beach if high tide
which is at 1:00 this afternoon if
that's when a durian hits here that
could be real trouble
Anthony mark thank you